if you want me to show up at your house
yes of course bro you want my address
here
right now this is the moment yeah I've
been saying you could pull up bro I'm
gonna give him my address so he just
cold dm'd me his address and I was like
what do you want to do with this bro so
I'm gonna come tomorrow Aiden you
invited me like a vampire I couldn't
come otherwise
this is my thing it's like brother you
can pull up on me I would love to talk
to you but any hate at all any type of
heat at all you're you're you're you're
you're gonna be asked respectfully
nicely to leave because I'm not here to
talk about hate I'm not here to talk
about useless conversation I'm here to
gain fit and spread love so I'm gonna
send you my address